auchan ou dans les usines des munitions
au tricot le rôle des femmes pendant la
première guerre mondiale a été
essentielle un hommage leur est rendu
aux clayes-sous-bois édite le poivre a
réalisé ses sculptures pour l'occasion
les hommes étaient partis au front et il
fallait continuer à vivre normalement et
faire vivre les villages les villes etc
donc j'ai voulu représenter tout ce
travail que les femmes ont fait à la
place des hommes il y a une histoire
mais je crois quand on plonge dedans
comme je lé fais au travers de ce
tableau et les précédents les couvre
beaucoup de choses et j'ai vraiment une
beaucoup d'admiration beaucoup
d'admiration pour ces femmes
cela fait trois ans qui dit participer
au centenaire 14-18 des clayes-sous-bois
un événement pour transmettre la mémoire
d'un des conflits les plus meurtriers de
notre histoire
l'exposition mise en place à l'espace
philippe noiret retrace plusieurs
facettes du rôle des femmes
l'occasion de découvrir qui est elle est
marraine de guerre
la marraine de guerre c'était ces femmes
qui faisait des colis et des lettres
qu'ils adressaient et qui était adressé
aux soldats sur le front pour embellir
entre guillemets à leur quotidien
on a aussi ses apports visuel qui
permette qui permettent de mettre des
images sur des mots sur des choses dont
on a entendu parler ça aide les enfants
à mettre des images
ils sont toujours très curieux si de
voir des objets exposition accessible
jusqu'au 19 novembre
la soirée de lancement du centenaire 14
18 est prévue en compagnie des filles
aux mains jaunes le 10 novembre
une plongée dans le quotidien des obus
êtes ces femmes qui fabriquait les obus
jusqu'à en avoir les mains jaunes
manche était parfois prendre un grand
bol de la parité qui fait qu un dimanche
par mois si on a de l'agencé en plus
beaux draps gueule pas avec vous